Not paying attention.
I don't know.
I don't know. I think
I just felt like they
were under estimating
I feel like the one.
Strawberry, like you visually?
We have, we have another
transcription.
No, no.
Hospital. He's very stalking High,
were you?
going to,
Yeah, it's jumping up.
Always.
When you are driving. And
when you are prescribing, you
always.
And then it goes wrong.
Voices.
And when you up from
school, so you have to
really pay attention to all
of those shoes.
You know, the saying that
she is more going on?
Going on.
You already mentioned.
I don't know. I'm trying
to put myself in this
position.
And I feel like I
would be like if the
first thing that comes in.
Brazilian in Germany.
Going on. So something.
German.
And invisible.
Which one is Brasilia.
Probably.
What special friend?
She was in Rochester.
So we have Parts off
of it. Lifted propping up,
we have him. Here is
a test and just looking.
We have we have seen
Call sweetheart.
Something between them may be
there.
we have raised their hands
so I can
Give me a question.
Jordans.
Play Poison you since forever.
I don't know.
Possibility.
Yeah, but of course there
are always small things involved
with could not show here
and there
The conversation.
Call Sis. What's a very
interesting and good conversation between
all of them and the
Brazilians didn't exist. They thought
it was very evident.
But is this is not
so different.
This is also.
I was just going to
comment on the gesture that's
G4 makes when he's like
saying vision and I think
it's like the worst Vision
systems you know.
Unlike their faces in an
indirect way.
Mario.
Just going back to the
question of what we can
see here and what we
can see what's up.
Maybe at once.
Volume up the boys for
example, life.
Talking to other people. And
in this case is also
very useful to have the
acting so depressed.
Three girls something in an
exact moment. So by looking
at the second shower,
Interesting.
Sometimes.
Types of attempt to make
this clear up for them.
And if he offended by
this,
Flashlight.
This is really important for
the game.
I would love to be
analyzing days like the whole
day of a lot of
to have like, a
It's a super interesting discussion
but we are completely cutting
the time. So I would
just like to ask. Should
we continue the discussion and
maybe Outsource another part to
a lady for the should
we wrap up the discussion?
So, we can't put like
a muse.
But just, you know, in
order for this discussion not
to just, you know, drown,
we could also open a
new telegram canal in order
to continue the discussion. If
you are very because I
feel it's really a lot
of interest in this year
and we can think of.
I also for you if
you interested in such an
analysis, this would be a
perfect thing. You can do
in your final video for
example just as
Is an idea.
And in the videos will
not be and I will
give you will give you
some tools, how to systematically
analyze hand gestures, and facial
gestures so that you can
actually really put it into
words. Basically what you see
in a more systematic manner.
Okay then I would like
to invite the second group
from today's the 22 presented,
the crunch text, right? So
the floor is yours and
Flavia will as I already
told you, I'm telling you
when 25 minutes is over
and then when it's only
10 minutes and five minutes
before the end so that
you have a good time
planning.
Maybe, do you need to
share screen? Should we do
that?
I don't see the option
here.
Okay.